il ya une vidéo qui a qui circule sur
les réseaux sociaux où on voit
effectivement maeva avec quelque chose
au niveau du nez y en avait eu une jambe
et on
avait une avec greg est également est
effectivement tout le monde se pose la
question de savoir si si la drogue dans
la télé réalité et je sais que magali
voilà on se connaît bien elle va dire
que non mais malheureusement oui c'est
cesser ses limites même plus à se créer
un secret de dire qu'il ya de la drogue
dans la télé réalité il ya même des
candidats qui ont été condamnées pour
trafic de stupéfiants donc donc voila
vous allez vers ce qui se passe quand et
les rites et dans un instant juste nous
on va voir la vidéo on voulait pour
montrer cette image qui tourne depuis
hier on y boit maeva renifler de manière
sûre voilà elle relie voilà elle un
petit boîtier dorés sont pas trop
couvert de poudre blanche on va voir cet
extrait qui a fait énormément parler
vous allez voir après les explications
de maybach
samudra sera italien qui l'année alors
il très gentil et tout ça mais il ne
correspond pas j'ai déjà amoureuse dans
ma vie et je sais ce que c'est le
sentiment de tomber amoureuse mais là
que je ressens pour dylan
malheureusement c'est toujours rien
voilà alors maeva et je sais que maeva
priori ça s'est fait une grosse connerie
complet voilà voilà dites nous pourquoi
mais c'est une grosse connerie parce
qu'elle a montré sur ça heureusement est
vraiment elle a une bande eu avec elle
comme quoi on peut arriver à dire deux
beaucoup de conneries alors on l'a
montré sa vie et voilà elle a gardé son
truc regardez alors on la mettait la
vidéo on ne me suis jamais drogué de
toute ma vie je me donnerai jamais je
suis en qui drogue voilà et que vous
avez vues dans les marseillais c'est
cette palette que océane m'a donné une
autre bien la palette vous voyez en fait
le d'aurier voyez ça sur le plastique
est en fait celle du doré par dessus et
en fait ça sans enlever ça abîme et
voilà je ne vous mens pas c'est
incroyable ça quand même franchement sûr
c'est vrai que c'est fou cette affaire
bon pour maëva c'est fou on va parler
l'aprilia ces grecs ccc l'ex de miley
c'est ça mais greg il a été à plusieurs
reprises surpris avec de la cocaïne
apparemment regarder
jamais de ma vie je me remettrai jamais
de ma vie je me remettrai jamais de ma
vie je me remettrai coin et sans
problème le je crois que c'est
simplement elle a eu une encéphalite et
à 19 ans la hulme myocardite ce qui fait
que de toute manière elle est en état
tant on sait que la drogue et manière
c'est dangereux mais en plus pour une
personne qui a tué ses deux mâles en
dise un peu là dessus et donc et ses
tourments moi je vais vous dire quelque
chose m'arrive a essayé une fois il m'a
permis de le dire parce qu'elle voulait
le dire parce que mme eva assume ce
qu'elle est et ce qu'elle fait elle a
pris une fois du joint hier elle a fumé
toujours joué
mais
je ne le fait pas ne fait ni joindre à
venise où adam boni joint de culasse
c'est très mauvais bien qu'un masque
après non mais après pour faire tout la
ville toute la ville en chose à cette
année est resté on l'a amené aux
urgences aller reste hospitalisé à la
timone et c'est moi
s'il vous plaît il ya des règles ici
machine faut que tu les comprennent
quand je parle juste je me tais charme
et oui voilà c'est exactement ça tu vois
si non c'est non tout le monde parle en
même temps c'est pas possible tu vois
ici on n'est pas chez les marseillais je
te dise il ya des règles voilà je n'ai
rien lu sur l'ap sur la téléralité
fait pas forcément bon même si tu viens
de te d'annoncer qu'elle avait quand
même essayé une fois c'est pas c'est pas
la joie voilà ce n'est pas le seul et
pas la personnalité ou effectivement on
a eu des fautes manque des choses de ce
type après clairement sur les
marseillais oui il ya de la drogue nous
on avait fait il ya de la drogue ou est
ce qu'ils se droguent parce que la vraie
question c'est est-ce qu'ils se droguent
en dehors des plateaux et c'est
catastrophique enfin tout est ce que si
le rire le lot est ce que c'est pour
nourrir le point où est-ce que c'est
dont la maison par exemple nous avions
fait une enquête une journaliste de
public annabelle jeantaise avait fait
une enquête l'année dernière et elle
avait eu notamment emilie amar qui a
nous avait expliqué sur le tournage des
marseillais en australie qu'elle avait
pris pour la première fois un rail de
coke avec une une influence eu une
saveur de satellites à nice ça viendra
lorsque ce qui nous expliquait on a eu
plusieurs candidats qui nous l'ont
expliqué effectivement c'est que il
demandait souvent aux vigiles d'aller
leur chercher de la drogue ou même à des
gens de la boîte de prod mais ces
quelques temps moi je demande un truc à
mokhtar saddam chercher des makrouts 1
c'est tout mais c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis longtemps même à la star
ac au début sa coloc à la star ac' y
distribuer de la drogue également dans
secret story les verres d'alcool il
comme il s'était fait ok par par le csa
il mettait des verts il mettait des
verres de couleur pour pas qu'on voit
qu'il est bourré afin d'animer le jeu
c'est quelque chose d'hyper courant et
sur les tournages effectivement il ya de
la drogue qui est fourni aux candidats
il ya même de la drogue c'est très grave
pour nous maintenant tu veux pas dire ça
mais je l'affirmé mais mais mais même si
voilà je risque un procès en diffamation
mais il ya même certains candidats je me
souviens de jeremstar qui a expliqué
qu'une fois il avait il avait parlé avec
une candidate qui avait manqué de faire
une overdose parce qu'elle avait planqué
de la drogue dans son temps pacs pour
pouvoir la mener sur le tournage donc
donc voilà c'est que c'est pas ces voix
là c'est ce sont des jeunes qui alors on
par benjamin castaldi j'en avais fait au
cas lorsque la mer est sûre sur secret
story la vérité c'est que on savait que
sa rentrée on cherchait g20 commence à
rentrer et ça fait qu'ils aient une
saison qu'elle est peu compliqué pour
nous il ya des caméras partout vous
n'êtes pas des réformes mais maintenant
oui je vous le dis la vérité c'est que
il y avait un onzième est un système de
livraison qui passait par les cols de
chemise et la blanchisserie essentielle
quel de dire oui effectivement il
envoyait dans un châle et quand il
revenait bien propre dans l'école il y
avait effectivement la cocaïne et on l'a
trouvée comme ça c'est alors par contre
je vous rejoint pas je crois pas du tout
que la prod non ma complice sur c'était
pas du couscous était pas moi c'est
l'autre mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait
des problèmes de livraison de cocaïne
des dépôts m2 de deux berges etc mais ça
c'est inhérent à la télé était depuis le
début vous avez quoi comme ce qu'on va
nous dire parce que si c'est pas un
scoop que dans secret story ont été
rendus compte qu'ils avaient eu des
livraisons
hebdomadaires sur l'homme et sur le loft
sur le loft sur l'oeuvre en deuxième
saison il y avait un des candidats qui
étaient connus pour consommer de la deux
un peu j'ai oublié non et on savait très
bien que il faisait rentrer de l'awb du
produit dans leur maison parce que sans
ça ils étaient mécontents dépression est
pas bien alors bio bio sur les sur la
manière dont les candidats se procure de
la drôme souvent ses émissions elles
sont tournées à l'étranger dans des
villas de luxe qui sont souvent à
proximité de quartiers extrêmement
pauvres où la drogue circule fascinant
la crise passé que la nuit quand il n'y
a plus d'équipé de production plus de
caméraman savoir faut un vigile parfois
pas les candidats sortent de la villa
comme d'envoi dans des favelas se
procurer de la drogue et mais
malheureusement personne ne peut s'en
rendre compte parce que l'on peut pas
mettre un vigile par candidat tout le
temps voilà donc ce n'est pas la
production capa
je suis un peu sidéré lorsque j'entends
mais qu'est ce que vous faites quand un
moment donné vous arrivez à savoir qu'il
ya des sacs de drogue parce que pour une
chaîne de télévision c'est quand même on
parle de ça il ya 10 ou 15 ans mais là
on parle aujourd'hui
d'une fête dans ces cas là quand il ya
de la drogue j'avais bu d'imac là oui
j'ai eu l'image mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait à ce moment-là plus on fait rien on
les laisse continuer à tourner dans une
fouille est conviée non on fait quoi il
sait nous nous on a effectivement quand
on a découvert le trafic avec ses
chemises hommes on s'en fout qu'il soit
fouillé on fait quoi après cette image
alors que venus a admis dans les bières
de 90 m à roullens que la téléréalité
est vérolé mais en fait je depuis depuis
le début en fait c'est pas la faute des
candidats les pauvres conditions et les
peaux participants c'est des rats de
laboratoire en fait et moi j'en veux
énormément à la prendre parce qu'au quai
sont pas complices mais malgré tout ils
sont complices parce que c'est ce qu'ils
recherchent ils recherchent le buzz et
recherchera non ils cherchent mais que
les gens sortent de leurs gonds qui se
parlent mal que ça coco c'est pas vrai
ça malheureux
canton et sans substance j'ai râlé les
bains on se parle j'ai alors je serais
pas là aucune faute de france alors
qu'aucune porte de françois desnoyer
complice de ça que la prod orienté
n'étions pas présents mais c'est vrai
que ça marche plus et non mais alors ils
vont laisser parce que ça on en parle ça
re domicile par nice a fait
les images par dont vous parlez d'une
image mais vous rendez compte de ce que
vous dites vous reprenez une image qui
est fausse et marib en défaut sur les
téléphones
comment savez vous les foyers qui sont
couchés
[Applaudissements]
dans mes frères je tourne un peu il a
choisi la fédé travailler dur
on est
sortis tous
je
[Applaudissements]
suis n'avait magali magail la gagner
c'est magali c'est pas s est pas zemmour
mélenchon là où tu es non mais je vous
le dis non mais dont vous laisser dire
ça mais bon deep house qu'on a été bien
suivi un très joli concédée c'est
interdit prend de la drogue il ne faut
commenter ce match at il commenté fixe
est immanente explique cette image
jamais il a fait des crêpes à
danser vous avez vu la halle a fait la
photo de miley
[Musique]
va connaître de défendre les marchés
je défends s'arrête sur des portions
business oui c'est normal que tu fasses
à chantonnay des pactes à [ __ ] j'ai
trop connu les gens à qui paul griffen
d'école à paris comme s'il vous plaît
nicolas permis mais non mais vous avez
des descentes harry john bon ça marche
mais aujourd'hui
c'est une dizaine on est quand même en
train de banaliser des images ultra gras
vous rendez compte qu'en 1986 en france
ont arrêté sur les plateaux télé de
fumée et l'alcool est aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qu'on voit des années après des gens
qui prennent qui ont le nez plein de
cocaïne et qui passent à la télévision
comme ça vous vous trouvez pas qu'à un
moment donné quelque chose de grave
l'espace comment vous expliquer cette
image c'est vous mais dangereux
mois magali berda magali vers la région
vous dire un truc moi un moment il faut
arrêter de dire de lire des dvd des
inepties arrêté tout le monde le sait
arrêtez de mentir excusez-moi pas les
gagner vous savez on dit en fait c'est
quand même c'est pas sur les antennes
des
shoguns il a été bien fait
j'ai eu sur moi
c'est parce qu'ils ont été isolés 18e
quand même de la prison avec suris match
complet mais moi je n'ai pas de
m'accueillir et être alors messieurs
plein juste greg grecs on est alors
d'accord grec c'est fou mahé vendée sur
ces faux grecs aux idéaux mais un
candidat qui a été dopé en donne un nom
mais si vous devez arrêter tout le monde
le sait et on a justifié de gestion sur
les chemins est-ce que vous pouvez nous
assurer aujourd'hui cas pas de drogue
dans les marseillais ou dans une autre
et des rallyes passionné aujourd'hui
voilà drogue humain même moi je peux
vous assurer ses capotes vendant de la
drogue ce qui est un passé je vous dis
y'a pas de banque s ils sont cons
actuellement
ces drogués ou d'avoir la drogue il est
exclu sur le champ et ça c'est la norma
nord est et nord est et même du foyer au
père noël elle croit rabbi jacob bella
deficom rania comme angel concombre anja
voit bien qu'ils sont pas
cons etc ont expliqué que sur les anges
fric et pas l'autre vidéo dit la vérité
monde sait qu'il ya des banques sur les
tournages et c'est pas vrai que les
candidats sont systématiquement il se
marre bien sûr que quand il ya des
preuves matérielles à paris à la cité
personne c'est effectivement une image
peut être détournée mais tout le monde
sait qui a de la drogue et personne ne
dit rien et oui voilà il ya des sisters
qu'il n'y en ait pas des bides il est
pas beau linge et
magali en fait vous prenez le mauvais
exemple avec maeva parce que maeva pas
maeva on sait que mal est basé sur les
[ __ ] un accès non moins à la drogue est
rien à gratter sur de santé voilà les
engagés contre ça c'est sûr voilà mais
arrêtez de défendre l'indéfendable sur
le reste on sait tous ici on l'a dit sur
ce plateau qui a des productions qui ont
été complices quand encourager ça non
moi j'ai une question à vous poser
savage armes a dit non non
les yeux j'avais écouté ferme les yeux
c'est pas genre à catane le centre est
fermé
de moi que je vous dis que les gens qui
dirigent ces boîtes de prod aller mais
qui dirige sage vous dès qu'ils font
abscons pas compris que de ça maintenant
que les mecs se mettent d'accord avec un
texto
aux cadres et salariés de la poste c'est
de la complicité
et
oui vous même si vous le saviez vous
êtes complice bras
[Rires]
je leur ai dit en tout cas maeva c'est
niet joliette et sur suma israël a rien
à voir là dedans mais non on parle d'une
général mais ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'on a des désirs gfr aujourd'hui
maintenant est ce qu'on prend pas de
l'appeler pour rien est ce que est ce
que ces émissions de télé réalité avant
elle avait une odeur une vertu si kabze
de l'audience aujourd'hui il n'y en a
pas une qui marche tout est mort même
les marseillais qui était la plus courte
de télé réalité aujourd'hui merci et
vivote entre 350000 et 450 milles
sectateurs max donc à quoi ça sert max
donc
sans diffuser avant ils vivotent mais
dès qu'on les conteneurs non non non pas
du tout évidemment ils sont 18 à 20
heures non ils sont diffusés avant sur
les plateformes faisais moi vous n'allez
pas m'apprendre la télé oui oui oui les
séquelles pascal marconville diffuse que
sur les plateformes alors c'est soit les
plateformes ils sont liés
essentiellement pas sur wii mais il
manque collectif est ce que sur salto
alors
nous si on fait 350 mille
téléspectateurs on va être en battant
salto arrière
vous le dit et on va rentrer chez nous
oui non les audiences aux mauvaises
avance les candidats sont toujours des
stars sur instagram ils sont bien sûr
john faudrait je pense ça serait bien
qu'ils s'expriment sur scène c'est pas
mais moi plus on appelle ça dort royal
appelant que j'adorerais magath
l'adorent ayatollahs dorment à la bonne
réaction de dire que c'est pas mal à
prendre de la drogue les douaniers il y
en a plein de regrets que je connais pas
mais voilà c'est l'ex de miley va donc
voilà le mien mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas moi moi je moi je vous dire il faut
un gendarme un moment voilà c'est tout
c'est tout il n'y a pas de chef voilà
c'est tout c'est simple non voyons pas
bien sûr jean verney magali les princes
ont été arrêtés les princes ont été
arrêtée faute d'audience c'était la
version officielle moi j'ai une question
sincère à vous poser est ce que les
princes ont aussi été arrêtés parce
qu'avais des bad buzz possible et
éventuellement parce qu'on s'est aperçu
qu'il pourrait y avoir de la drogue qui
circulait dans les princesses que c'est
une des raisons de l'arrêt de l'émission
va pas se mentir il faut pas être
hypocrite il y en a eu cette saison
dacquois la d2 la drogue et je pense que
c'était pas du tout le sujet c'était pas
si j'ai cette saison dans les prince par
contre il ya eu des bad boys c'est
monsieur déboussolé puisqu'on en a parlé
ici sur ce plateau plusieurs fois et les
audiences parce qu'aucune chaîne elle a
aidé bad buzz et aussi des problèmes
d'audience à elles des programmes donc
ça les arrange pas les chaînes qui est
des problèmes et que savait qu'on va
saper sur salle parce que j'ai défilé
mardi mines téléspectateurs sur salto
rien de plus aucun jeune et à bonas alto
ça change rien à l'audience m dire ouais
mais ce que c'est pas tout simplement la
mort cérébrale de la télé réalité comme
ça comme un l'a entendue chez moi je
trouve que ces jeunes ils ont du talent
mais il faut qu'il fasse autre chose
maintenant on a des prises pour l'un
d'eux mêmes à la rentrée des deux
restaurants ça c'est bien il faut il
fait alors yacco pas moi qui me dit
magali qui dit que les candidats qui ne
prennent pas de drogue est aussi
crédible que moi si je disais que
j'étais et aux hétéros alors il est très
drôle ou alors maintenant mais magali
parce que je sais que vous vous défendez
vos candidats et c'est très bien de
défendre ses équipes mais c'est pas mon
équipe quand vous demandez défendre
c'est jusqu'à un moment en a en avant
les choses ça peut peut-être faire
évoluer les choses ça va aller presser
sur ces bourses avaient protégé pris la
parole et c'est très important de le
faire mais en soit moi je suis désolé je
ne vais pas condamné si j'ai pas une
preuve moi tant que j'ai pas vu l'un
d'entre eux se droguer je ne dirai
jamais que sa gang je vais vous parler
les gens avaient les autres stades et
vous les mettez dans les mêmes choix
mais je vais pas dire fera plaisir et
j'ai pas le dire poursuit mois vous êtes
rentré dans les marseillais ou dans la
dynamique heures
je peux vous garantir que jamais bien
rail de coke sera-t-il animé pendant
trois mois la cocaïne marty aujourd'hui
les jeunes sont dans les sourires
étaient incroyables marseille et aux
trois pas derrière mais est ce que vous
y êtes vous aussi demande si je n'ai
marien pas tomber ll nous donne des
infos alors pour savoir où on a eu quand
même beaucoup de candidats qui nous en
ont parlé pas bien sûr mais aussi si le
chien qui parle elle chante dément tout
soit ils sont tous des menteurs des
[Rires]
[Musique]
motivations et des bayards ça veut rien
dire ça aussi nous même si oui mais
s'ils ont su réagir serez très surpris
dans les tueries ci ont surréagi je peux
vous dire n'y en a pas un qui prend de
la coke ici voilà donc anthony et robin
heureusement oui sinon je lui casse le
cul mais en finlande où le dit non mais
c'est vrai mais la maison faut virer
dire eh ben voilà il faut virer direct
exactement mais j'ai fait plusieurs
tournages ya plusieurs années et là où
la production est intraitable sur
certaines choses comme la violence comme
termes absolument didac de voir le
traiteur intraitable car marc mais il ya
des quatre candidats lève la main sur
l'autre immédiatement exclu sur la
drogue qui ferment complètement les yeux
ils s'en foutent ils le savent ils
voient qu'ils sont drogués en soirée il
les voit prendre de la drogue et voilà
ça se paye cher
car il ya 15 ans
fondée claude wicky à loreto la pause
n'est pas la cause mais ils ont ils
doivent s'engager à ne pas prendre de
substances illicites
il fait valoir c'est comme au tour de
france sept
îles a appris d'après mais c'est
interdit mais pour que la production
bien sûr exactement simplement sa lettre
étatique mais non mais non c'est ce qu'a
promis à la guérison c'est pour la
foulée c'est bien parce que la
production se couvrent parfois il peut
faire juste il ya un ami à moi qui fais
a fait date et l'arrêté qui m'envoient
tirer pour convient pas aux télé réalité
avec un vrai sens un vrai truc un vrai
enjeu voilà c'est vrai mine de rien
voilà aujourd'hui c'est n'importe quoi
alors il y avait le loft et c'était
nouveau à l'époque donc c'est vrai on y
voit la soldate story aussi mais c'est
vrai que là bon ça ça franchement ça
tourne rond ont envoyé même les délais
marseille je trouve qu'ils ont
énormément de talent on en a plein qui
coûte talent je pense que pourrait faire
autre chose en soi faire la même chose
avec eux mais autre chose c'est-à-dire
un nouveau concept avec la bande qui est
très bonne mais là les marseillais les
maxima cergy pontoise où les marseillais
non mais chez ma mère on s'en tape total
ça y est c'est bon ils ont fait le tour
du monde après on en a rien avant
voilà les marseillais au mexique non
mais sans déconner moi je ne vous cache
pas qu'on connaît ce que je fais chier
quelqu'un en bas voilà
elle fait son écharpe récit c'est
magnifique ma fille adore et voilà greg
qui chante c'est un cas un coeur un
back-to-back on casse la baraque l'hôtel
field récit et le fait que si notre
ambulance en moi même dit non et que les
gens les aiment c'est qu'on a dit mais
le met la tête de sioux c'est parce que
les gens les uns mais le concept est à
chier et ça fait trois cent cinquante
mille téléspectateurs aux quatre cent
mille téléspectateurs ben voilà il est
là vous allez me dire c'est vrai ça
passe sur salto donc ça fait trois cent
soixante mille mercis c'est mon dernier
mot merci mag est louche je d'autre
chose bah écoutez je vais défendre notre
bifteck c'est normal non c'est pas
débile tex et des valeurs humaines je
vais pas accuser khalfallah ne pas juste
pour regarder les marchés bondés les
marseillais mais je les connais ici
toute la journée moi aussi je connais
des gens bien comme ça hein je connais
très bien perdre un marché
grec je les connais mieux que personne
je sais à qui j'ai affaire et je peux
pas laisser dire des choses mais on a
des cas soit gré des live à l'accord on
les sort mais on sait qu y en a mais
mais mais y en a partout bien sûr qu'il
faut lui apprendre ça c'est un flic le
butin sur la dronne il faut là il faut
la stopper et bien sûr qu'il faut
l'interdire ça fait trois pas vous dire
le contraire et l'autre est venu marlène
schiappa
lol non mais sans dec merci magali berda
la prochaine fois soyez plus honnête tu
savais que je vous aime beaucoup mais
attention le business c'est bien
l'honnêteté c'est mieux ça y est
[Applaudissements]